D'ordinaire dans cette station balnéaire
égyptienne, même en décembre,
il y a plus de monde
dans l'eau que sur la plage.
Mais cette année,
étrangement, malgré la chaleur,
les touristes restent tranquillement
allongés sur leur transat
ou se contentent d'admirer
les poissons du haut des pontons.
-Vous n'allez pas vous baigner ?
Non, c'est dangereux de se baigner.
On a juste le droit
de marcher au bord de l'eau.
Et quand une touriste décide
de s'aventurer dans l'eau,
elle est immédiatement rappelée
à l'ordre par un garde.
Comme elle ne l'écoute pas,
il lui mime
le danger qui la guette.
Et il lui écrit : shark, shark,
ce qui veut dire requin en anglais.
Car ces dernières semaines,
des requins sèment la terreur
et empêchent les touristes
de se baigner dans les eaux turquoise
de Charm el-Cheikh, en Égypte.
Cette station balnéaire
située sur les bords de la mer Rouge,
attire chaque année
plusieurs millions de touristes.
Si elle a autant de succès,
c'est grâce à ses fonds marins
et sa faune aquatique exceptionnelle,
qu'il est facile d'observer
à seulement
quelques mètres de profondeur.
Mais depuis deux mois,
c'est un requin
comme celui-ci qui provoque la panique.
C'est un longimanus.
Il peut mesurer
jusqu'à trois mètres de long
et il fait partie des requins
les plus dangereux au monde,
car il ose s'attaquer à l'homme.
C'est ce qu'il n'a pas hésité
à faire le 30 novembre dernier.
Cette touriste russe
se baigne tranquillement
au bout d'un ponton,
quand le requin l'attaque.
Il la mutile à la fesse,
aux bras et à la jambe.
Elle est sortie
de l'eau in extremis.
Le lendemain,
le requin repasse à l'attaque.
Un autre nageur russe
se fait déchiqueter le bras.
Au moment où le requin a attaqué,
je me suis enfui de l'eau très vite.
Le nageur a commencé
à se battre avec le requin,
puis il a crié :
"Il y a un requin, aidez-moi !"
À ce moment-là,
tout le monde s'est sauvé.
En deux jours,
quatre touristes sont grièvement blessés.
L'alerte au requin
se répand dans le monde entier.
Beaucoup de vacanciers
risquent d'annuler leur séjour.
Pour éviter de perdre
leur saison touristique,
les autorités égyptiennes
ferment les plages
et se lancent dans une chasse
aux requins de grande envergure.
Et comme par hasard,
deux squales sont immédiatement capturés
et présentés comme les tueurs.
Pour preuve, on exhibe
à la presse du monde entier
leur impressionnante mâchoire.
Selon les autorités,
il n'y a alors plus de danger.
Les plages sont rouvertes,
mais deux jours plus tard,
la psychose est relancée.
Une touriste allemande se fait dévorer
au bord de la plage de cet hôtel de luxe
et meurt de ses blessures.
La baignade est de nouveau interdite
alors que des centaines de vacanciers
débarquent à Charm el-Cheikh.
Certains Égyptiens, pris de panique
de voir les touristes repartir,
veulent montrer aux journalistes
du monde entier que tout va bien.
Regardez,
je suis moniteur de plongée
et moi je vous dis qu'il n'y a pas
de problème à Charm el-Cheikh.
Vous êtes de la télévision ?
Il n'y a aucun problème.
Venez nager avec moi.
Pour rassurer les touristes,
ils n'hésitent pas à braver le danger
et l'interdiction de se baigner.
Charm el-Cheikh,
il n'y a pas de problème.
Alors pourquoi
ce requin qui d'habitude
chasse à plusieurs kilomètres
des côtes en pleine mer,
s'est-il approché si près
des plages de Charm el-Cheikh ?
Et pourquoi s'est-il
attaqué à l'homme ?
Magali plonge au milieu des requins
depuis plusieurs années.
Cette Française,
monitrice de plongée à Charm el-Cheikh,
n'a jamais connu une seule attaque.
-C'est irréel ce qui
se passe en ce moment.
C'est complètement inhabituel.
Ce n'est pas un comportement naturel
du requin d'attaquer l'homme.
Ça fait dix ans que je suis ici,
que je côtoie des requins régulièrement,
on n'a jamais eu
de soucis comme ça.
Normalement, aujourd'hui, Magali
doit encadrer ce groupe de plongeurs.
-Bonjour les gars.
-Mais comme chaque matin
depuis les attaques,
elle ne sait pas si les autorités
vont lui laisser prendre la mer.
Elle vient aux nouvelles
auprès d'un de ses collègues.
-Ça va ?
-Ça va et toi ?
On n'est pas rasé ?
Quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui ?
Donc on ne charge rien.
On va sur le bateau,
on fait nos plongées et on revient.
Demain, on ne sait pas encore.
La baignade en bord de plage
est interdite.
Mais pour éviter que
les clubs de plongée ne fassent faillite,
les autorités permettent aux plongeurs
expérimentés de se jeter à l'eau.
Les gens viennent ici pour plonger
et si vous fermez la plongée,
c'est une catastrophe.
Il faut aussi préserver.
C'est ça qui est difficile
de trouver un juste milieu
entre la protection des gens
et leur sécurité
et puis faire plaisir aux gens
qui sont venus pour ça.
-Magali et trois de ses collègues
emmènent une vingtaine
de vacanciers en pleine mer,
plonger aux abords d'un récif
situé à une heure
de bateau des côtes.
Parmi tous ces sportifs,
il y a un groupe de Russes.
C'est la plus importante clientèle
de Charm el-Cheikh.
Une clientèle
qui aime plonger parmi les requins.
Et ils le revendiquent
jusque sur leur tee-shirt.
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est où on rencontre des requins.
C'est vraiment quelque chose
que les gens veulent.
On porte des tee-shirts sur les requins...
C'est quelque chose qu'on a envie de voir.
Ça fait partie du Graal.
La quête du Graal,
allez voir les requis.
Oui. À peu près cinq fois.
Ici, j'en ai vu un une fois.
Sinon, je vais aux Maldives.
Ce ne sont pas les attaques
de ces derniers jours
qui vont les décourager.
Tous ces plongeurs
savent comment se comporter
face à ce dangereux prédateur.
On sait tous
que les requins ont peur des bulles.
Ça les repousse.
Mais comment
vous faites des bulles ?
On lâche l'air des bouteilles
et ça fait des bulles.
Les bulles permettent de tenir les requins
à distance, comme sur ces photos.
Mais vous devez surtout faire attention
quand vous remontez en surface,
car à ce moment-là,
ils peuvent vous prendre pour une proie.
Tous les spécialistes le disent,
c'est vu du dessous que vous êtes
le plus appétissant pour un requin.
Mais le plus important,
c'est de garder son calme,
son sang-froid face à la bête.
Si un requin qui vient,
et devient curieux,
on reste bien groupé, on reste calme,
on lui fait face et puis on l'attend.
-On lui fait face.
-On lui fait face toujours, on regarde.
En général, il s'en va.
Il y a rarement des cas
où le requin vient tout près du plongeur.
Aujourd'hui, pas besoin
de mettre en pratique ces recommandations.
Au fond de l'eau, pas de requins,
juste des poissons multicolores.
À la sortie, certains sont déçus.
Il n'y avait pas de courant aujourd'hui,
c'était tranquille.
Pas de courants,
pas de requins.
Ce sera la fois prochaine.
On espère.
-Mais il y a une autre raison
qui peut attirer et énerver les squales.
Christian est moniteur de plongée,
pour lui, les requins sont une passion
et cette passion
a bien failli lui coûter la vie.
C'était en juin 2009,
alors qu'il plonge avec un groupe
dans le sud de l'Egypte.
Un requin s'approche de lui.
Ce jour-là, Christian
se rend compte que l'animal
n'a pas un comportement habituel.
Un plongeur filme la scène.
Normalement, il ne passe placidement pas
son chemin, jette un œil, regarde,
mais sans pour cela
se préoccuper plus que ça des plongeurs.
Mais pas en tout cas
des comportements comme ceux-ci,
ou le requin vient pratiquement
renifler le plongeur
pour voir s'il n'y a pas
quelque chose à manger.
-Là, il faut partir ?
C'est le bon moment de se dire
que c'est l'heure de remonter
et de sortir de l'eau.
-Pour éviter de se faire mordre,
Christian tient à distance
le requin grâce
à sa bouteille d'oxygène.
-Donc le requin, il vient, il va revenir.
Il ne va pas
se laisser décourager.
Il vient vraiment renifler la bouteille
et quand on essaye
de lui cogner le nez, il s'écarte.
-Les plongeurs n'en reviennent pas.
On entend même le caméraman effrayé,
crier dans son masque.
Christian est passé
tout près de l'accident.
Si le requin s'en est pris à lui,
ce n'est pas par hasard.
Quelques heures auparavant,
l'animal avait été attiré et excité
par de la nourriture jetée des bateaux.
Cette pratique dangereuse,
Christian a pu l'observer
de nombreuses fois
au large de la mer Rouge.
Quand on arrive avec le bateau
de croisière qui s'amarre au récif,
il y a les requins qui arrivent
parce qu'ils sont attirés
par la nourriture éventuelle
qui peut tomber du bateau,
les restes de nourriture, voire pire
des équipages des bateaux
qui parfois pour attirer les requins
exprès parce que les gens
veulent voir des requins,
vont jeter des morceaux de poulet.
Les requins à priori associés,
à ce moment-là,
le fait d'avoir des plongeurs
dans l'eau à au fait
d'avoir de la nourriture.
-Afin d'éviter les accidents,
jeter de la nourriture
pour attirer toute sorte de poissons
et des requins,
c'est strictement interdit
à Charm el-Cheikh.
Nous nous sommes rendus
chez les petits vendeurs de balades en mer
pour voir si cette interdiction
était bien respectée.
-Bonjour, je peux faire
une balade en mer ?
-La concurrence est telle
que certains vendeurs inconscients
sont prêts à contourner la loi
pour vendre leurs excursions.
-On peut voir beaucoup de poissons ?
Oui, beaucoup de sortes de poissons.
Moi, je veux en voir de toutes sortes.
Et est-ce qu'on peut les nourrir ?
Oui, mais il faut être discret.
Je peux en parler au capitaine
pour qui vous laisse
nourrir les poissons.
-Je dois apporter de la nourriture ?
Non, pas besoin d'en amener.
Sur le bateau,
vous avez votre repas.
Je peux prendre
la nourriture du bateau.
-Oui.
-Et si on les nourrit ?
Si vous jetez de la nourriture,
les poissons vont venir.
Et peut-être des requins ?
Je ne peux pas
vous le garantir.
-Il n'empêche que tous ces poissons
et cette nourriture,
cela favorise
la venue des requins.
Et le vendeur d'à côté
nous explique
que c'est une pratique courante.
-Beaucoup de touristes
nourrissent les poissons.
-Et vous ne dites rien ?
-Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je dise ?
Les gens sont là
pour se faire plaisir
et si ça leur fait plaisir,
et bien qu'ils le fassent.
-OK.
-Et l'une des explications
des attaques du mois dernier,
c'est précisément la nourriture.
Et là, c'était carrément un festin.
Pour enquêter, les autorités égyptiennes
ont fait venir l'un
des plus grands spécialistes
au monde des requins, George Burgess.
Après une semaine d'observation,
cet Américain aurait découvert
la raison de l'agressivité
du prédateur envers les baigneurs.
Au moment de la grande fête de l'Aïd,
chaque musulman doit sacrifier un mouton.
À cette époque, des bateaux remplis
de bêtes traversent la mer Rouge.
Certains moutons transportés sur un
bateau sont morts pendant le voyage.
Les marins les ont jetés
par-dessus bord.
On a retrouvé sur les côtes
plus d'une trentaine de carcasses.
C'est ce qui a certainement attiré
les requins près des plages.
-Pour ce spécialiste,
la seule solution,
c'est de maintenir
les plages fermées
le temps que les requins
repartent au large.
Ce sont des animaux
qui se déplacent beaucoup.
Il se peut très bien
qu'au moment où je vous parle,
les requins soient déjà repartis
au large de la mer Rouge.
Vous savez,
c'est la nature qui décide.
-Depuis notre reportage le mois dernier,
il n'y a pas eu
de nouvelles attaques de requins.
Les autorités égyptiennes ont estimé
que la sécurité était suffisante
pour rouvrir toutes les plages
de Charm el-Cheikh.